e
how far do you think we should go with
this your amendment is very brief so
that's I think I guess a positive
um the one thing that I heard loud and
clear in the couple other times that I
was before this committee was a desire
to have there be some real specificity
in terms of what map you know what what
disclosures about flood risk we're
talking
about um and I've attempted to I
attempted to address that in the last
amendment that you have which is um
128 by including language that says that
um and it's on page 30 uh page one lines
30 and
31 actually it starts on page two um so
that we are very clear that it's the
official Insurance flood map official
flood insurance map provided by FEMA as
of the date that a purchase that the
purchase and sale agreement is signed
and if the answer is yes to that
question then you attach a copy of that
official flood insurance map so I I I
hoped that that would address that that
specific
concern um the the amendment that you've
prepared um Mr chairman you know doesn't
get that specific I mean it just talks
about you know that that it's in a flood
zone and so that seems to go against the
direction that this subcommittee was
going when I was when I was
talking um the other thing that I did in
the amendment in Amendment 128 again at
the um well let me let me just follow up
on that the one thing that is still in
the amendment 128 is protection for a
seller who relies on someone else to
provide them with information about
flood disclosure that's that's Now new
section two in the amendment so that's
still in there to provide that
protection for
sellers um which I think is a is a is a
is a a significant benefit the other
thing that the amendment does which I
think reflects the a lot of the concern
that was expressed by the
subcommittee in previous discussions was
we've taken out everything relating to
to landlords and tenants it's completely
out um so that this bill only focuses on
sellers um there was a concern also
about there was a concern expressed
about having buyers kind of coign so
that they are acknowledging that you
know that that they know that there's a
flood risk what amendment 128 does by
including the language around flood
disclosure in a purchase and sale
agreement that must be signed by both
the seller and the buyer so that closes
that Loop so
um you know I I I think
128 is a is a
is a tighter a tighter bill in terms of
providing some
real um protection for buyers and
sellers um and um you know hopefully
addresses the specificity that you were
all looking
for okay representative M um this is a
question for for you Mr chairman you
said you negotiated with the Realtors
what what exactly was their their
holding point they will speak next next
I'm sorry they will speak next they will
speak now all
right and and and just to
clarify um the actual information on the
flood in uh insurance is not in the
purchase and sales agreement it's
actually in the disclosure agreement and
the disclosure agreement is made by the
the seller and the seller's agent when
the when the house is put on the market
so we keep referring to the the the uh
purchase and sales there is a question
in the purchase and sales but that's
completed by the buyer and the buyer is
asking about flood insurance and and
flood but again that information has
already or should have already been
provided by the seller so I just want to
clarify
that right so yeah so that that this
chart amendment is is uh amending what
needs to be in the purchase and sales
agreement
I I would have to agree with
representative M I think
am much
tighter really gets to the point as
opposed to being a little vague I think
well but we're trying to get it to the
purchase sale agreement which was as we
decide that's a more important document
Mr
chair yeah
um um the reason that um the language on
flood disclosure is included in RSA
4774 is that that's that's the RSA
that's referenced in the purchase and
sale agreement right so what this is
doing is adding flood disclosure at the
same level putting it at the same level
of importance hopefully putting it at
the same level of importance as radon
Arsenic and Lead which are currently in
the purchase and sale agreement right
okay any
other yes representative
Gibs thank you Mr chair um I agree with
representative melier that um the uh
Amendment
um sorry TW Amendment 128 uh I think it
is clearer than Amendment
1185 okay any other representa for
us thank you for taking my question so
where is the realtor in terms of
responsibility here is it lying strictly
with the um the seller and the buyer and
the people who provide the information
in terms of flooding Etc it it it's
really between the seller and the buyer
and and and I think um you know there
was a lot of discussion in the last
subcommittee about you know third party
this and third party that um and i' like
to thank representative melier here for
hope hopefully kind of bringing us back
to you know what we're really talking
about I mean the responsibility that
we're trying to create here is be is is
the it's the seller's responsibility if
the seller relies on someone else to
help them get that information realtor
professional engineer
whatever um then we're you know that's
up to the seller um we are providing
some protection for the seller that in
the event that that third party sorry to
bring that up again third party um you
know does something incorrect or
provides false information that the
seller has some recourse followup please
further question may inquire okay so I'm
still struggling I don't remember
representative spear said last time that
the realtor is making a commission on
the sale um um on of this so I I just a
little struggling with the fact that
there's you know if they are
representing the buyer that there's no
no responsibility there for any any
anything that happens as a result of
flooding
Etc yeah I don't I don't know that I've
got a real answer to that I mean the
only thing I would go back to is that
the purchase and sale agreement is
signed by the buyer the seller and the
buyer it's not signed by the agent okay
all right thank you representative M if
I can make a comment on that if the
seller's agent knows something they have
to divulge that as well not just the
seller but so in other words if the
selling agent knew that this was in a
flood zone but the seller didn't
indicate that it would be the
seller's agent that would have to
disclose that but shouldn't the seller
have done some the agents done some
digging um repeat that
please the realtor shouldn't they have
done some digging on their
own there I don't believe that the
selling agent is required to do that um
I think they would if they're doing the
right job for the seller they might also
look into it but again um if they don't
know information they're not required to
disclose what they don't know but if
they do know information they are
required to disclose it I hope that
answers
that okay so um just to make sure I'm
clear um we'll start with the section
two of the bill which is um obviously
starts at the bottom of page two which
is this flood risk
disclosure and um do do we have this
kind of language for for uh for lead or
uh arsonic or Raid on I don't think
so not not this not this whole remedy
section in terms of if you remember our
public hearing our subcommittee last
time was that that we got came down to
at the end of the day is that if a buyer
feels like they were
give misinformation or lack information
or incorrect information you were trying
to find some way that they could sue
them which
obviously you know that doesn't really
solve anything I mean in your mind it
might solve things but in my mind this
just creates another lawsuit and and a
financial burden on on that buyer so I'm
I wasn't too crazy about that and then
when I look if if it's also correct when
I look at what you're doing is that in
you're doing amending the putting all
this language that is in
a okay whereas um it in terms of where I
was looking in the statute was this um
was the 474 D you know Roman one where
what was needed specifically to be in
the purchase and sale agreement whereas
this is this
is uh how the best I would describe it
this is sort of um explanatory or
knowledge giving or helping people to
know what things they should know rather
than specifically saying whereas in what
in this our amendment is what exactly
needs to be in that purchas sale
agreement and really lay it out and
spell it out that that this these have
to be in there and but they end up
having the same result because they have
the result that we're we're saying a is
what's the flood zone which is what you
were concerned about where where is
where is what is the flood zone and and
two is whether that person had insurance
or not had flood insurance so it seems
like they both do the same thing it's
just that a is where you know be you
know where they're in and B is I don't
all I see in here is the stuff you're
saying they need to do but it doesn't
actually have that what we have in this
amendment specifically saying this needs
to be in that purchase sale
agreement um you know I I'll I'll I'll
defer to your understanding of the rsa's
you know over mine any day but I'm
looking at the purchase and sale
agreement right now right and it says in
compliance with the requirements of RSA
4774 Dasa the following information is
provided to buyer buyer blah blah blah
so that's that's what I started with I I
was trying to use an existing document
correct and I figured if I amended
477 4A that would then require flood
disclosure to be included on here right
well because that because the problem
was we when it comes to um Arsenic and
and the lead or radon I know if radon in
particular say is that the in terms of
testing but testing was never required
or never done it was really to inform
people that they should have it tested
but in terms of and then and so that
statue might s said if if it's been
tested but it never it never required to
be tested and so the idea is that you
want whatever we're requiring is we're
asking things that had to that that had
to have a positive answer you had to
have you have to tell you have to tell
them you know relative to the location
whether it's on a flood map or not
that's a requirement that is a positive
you have to do that and then and then
whether the seller has flood insurance
you they have to say yes or no and
that's what I thought you were trying to
get at do you wanted to get away from um
I don't know yeah no I mean we're trying
to make you know include specific
questions that have to be answered yes
or no okay yes okay any other questions
from the committee thank you very much
okay thank you members of the committee
it's it's been my thrill to be with you
these past three times so hopefully
we'll get to do it again
sometime
okay quen you're
up hello my name is Bob Quinn I am the
CEO of the New Hampshire Association of
Realtors I'm Joanie McIntyre I'm the
president of the Realtors
association so um I think if we
understand the intent behind the amended
version of the bill uh as representative
months um indicated it appears that um
what he wants to try and do is require a
seller to indicate whether or not um the
property is uh in a M area um so it
would be the only requirement uh in
statute or any place where a seller
would be mandated to have to answer yes
or no to a question um we do have
concerns about that in that what it's
sort of saying to um a buyer is hey
don't worry about doing your own due
diligence um trust what the seller is
telling you we don't think that's a good
idea it doesn't exist any place else on
our purchase and sale it doesn't exist
any place else in stat
uh in addition when you require that
this bill on page three under 540 D1 is
setting up a unique civil remedy for
flood insurance that would only apply to
issues regarding flood insurance so how
does that impact uh failure to properly
disclose on other issues such as septic
um private drinking water insulation Etc
you're setting up a unique
process just for flood
insurance and talking to our attorney he
wasn't sure why and he wasn't sure the
implications that that would have with
other disclosures so that's a real
concern for us and then in the final
section on page three section five it
says sort of okay seller you have to
answer yes or no but if you hire a
certified professional engineer or a
land surveyor then it's basically your
liability is going to be
removed so even if a seller would to
live on the side of a hill and they go
to their attorney and they look at the
purchase and sale agreement the the
attorney's probably going to say look if
you don't want any
liability you're going to want to hire a
land surveyor or professional engineer
in order to zero out that liability we
don't think that's necessary and we also
think that what is the proper thing to
do is to encourage buyers always to do
their own deal due diligence no matter I
think representative mcleer will tell
you this um president McIntyre will tell
you this we would always recommend even
if the seller brings information even if
it brings a a a test for water quality
on a private well buyers should always
do their own due diligence and doing
their own water test to to guarantee
that is correct this legislation is
pushing it in the other direction and
it's saying no no trust the seller the
seller's going to give you proper
information and I don't think that's the
right
direction um I would agree on that and I
would say just as a matter of
information for you we do not fill out
those disclosures in any way the the the
seller fills out the disclosure and we
are not responsible for digging in and
trying to find out more information and
if we have knowledge of something that
we know is material a material defect we
need to encourage the seller to disclose
that or we back out of the sale I don't
want to be in a in a imp party to
something where uh basement floods and
they say no don't tell anyone that's not
a that's not a a property that I want to
be involved in um if if a um seller
brings
um a water test from a year ago and
offers that to the buyer I would still
as a buyer represent representative ask
the buyer to do their own water test
things change um they would want the
most upto-date information and I would
say the same would be true about uh a
flood flood situation they should call
their insurance agent make sure that
it's not um in a flood zone I would not
um recommend that my buyers rely on
information given to them by the
sellers um Beyond they they really
should look into it on their own just to
to certify that it's
true and just to reiterate what the
chairman had mentioned earlier regarding
4774 a so those are the notifications on
radon arsic and lead and by the way um
the House of Representatives recently
passed a new notification requirement on
P pass uh which we do support and is on
the Senate side and I would expect that
to to pass as well so that would be the
fourth all of those have to do with um
contaminants um right on ARS neck lead
so things like um water supply and other
things which are mandated by the
legislature are in fact not in 4774 a um
but are in
4774 D so for consistency um we would
encourage that the change be made in
4774 D in the amendment I think there is
um the I think that the total lines that
would be added to our purchase and sale
for flood would be 36 lines um radon is
about five right now um arsonic is seven
so you are it is not I don't think
proportional in terms of notification I
think it would be sending a message to
buyers that the most important thing
they need to review in purchasing a home
is flood
insurance uh and I think that's probably
not a message that we particularly
should be sending uh to buyers I think
all of these things are are very
important um and need to be treated
equally yes a question
for thank you for taking my
question I think a buy
should really know about flood if if the
uh flood flooding if the property is in
a flood zone I think it should be
revealed that it is in flood zone
because this is 2024 I have photographs
from all throughout the state regarding
flooding that is occurring um almost
every time it rains now so I think it's
very important for a buyer to know if it
is in a flood zone and whether it's the
I think the realtor should be
responsible for
that that's that's what I
think so I can tell you a personal
situation I bought a condominium um 16
years ago in South Carolina and it was
not in a flood zone and has not been in
a flood zone for 15 years and I think it
may have been put in a flood zone in the
last year because of a special
assessment I received but I've I don't
have flood insurance and I can't say for
sure if it isn't in a flood zone so and
and actually that property is for sale
right now on my disclosure I checked
unknown um I really I honestly don't
know for sure and I looked it up this
morning um on the flood map and I still
can't
tell so I I think unknown is a is an
answer that that people might might put
there okay represent back um thank you
it it seems to me that in looking at uh
disclosures uh the the default message
is unknown so people haven't bothered to
look into this and they just check
unknown but you said you looked at the
flood map did did you look at the flood
map I did this morning I and and it
didn't say it was in a flood zone I
can't really tell from the flood map
it's very hard to um to interpret um I
would and I don't have in in this case I
don't have a mortgage on that um piece
of property
um I've my insurance company hasn't said
to be you're now in a flood zone if I
were representing
someone who were going to buy that
property it's not mine somebody else's
and I'm representing a buyer I would
check on on the purchase and sale that
that's one of their due diligence to
check pledge insurance and they would
call their insurance company for one and
the insurance company um Can interpret
them pretty well um and you know that I
would encourage them to do that due
diligence I wouldn't go by yes or yes or
no or unknown because if they say no and
their Ins Insurance company says yes
it's in a flood G should they not buy
flood
insurance repres represent burough so I
guess the thing I'm thanks for taking my
question the thing I'm struggling with
like in that scenario and you said you
didn't know obviously that was the that
was true did you have a responsibility
to ask professional you know call
whoever FEMA to find out what the story
was because I mean everybody could check
I don't
know with doing nothing
right so just to reiterate on the on the
property disclosure form right now um I
just want to just read it it says is
this property located in a federally
designated flood Hazard Zone yes no or
unknown now the property disclosure as
representative mle pointed out that is
filled out by the seller all right so
whether or not they know or don't know
um and if they have a realtor the
realtor is representing in that case the
seller if the buyer has their own agent
all right and the agent comes across
that and it says unknown then that buyer
agent would have some responsibility to
work with that client to identify
whether or not so if you're in I think
the example came up in Hampton you know
so if you're representing a a buyer in
Hampton you're an agent and you never
bring up the fact if you're the agent
that hey maybe we should go check the
flood zone look he said it's unknown you
are a liable all right I mean if if
something went wrong if that was
inaccurate information that was or it
wasn't even brought up um then that
agent is at Great legal risk uh in any
lawsuit so I think it is important to
keep in mind who fills out the property
disclosure form who fills out and signs
the purchas and sale and I will point
out that in the amendment on 477 D if
you read if you read the entire statute
it does require in all of these um that
it is written and that the buyer has to
accept it and acknowledge
um by signing it and that's what happens
on the on our form currently so they
would have to acknowledge that they've
received this representative
Gibs thank you
uh this is a question uh regarding the
example that was given about the South
Carolina property um where you couldn't
tell on the flood zone map whether the
property was in the flood zone or not
but isn't there someone that you could
call who could interpret that flood zone
map for you and so that you could
actually find out whether the property
is in a flood zone or not because a lot
of this came up because we heard a fair
amount of testimony about people who
thought their property wasn't in a flood
zone um and I guess when they bought it
unknown had been checked uh and they
thought there was no information but
then if they tried to get a mortgage the
bank told them it was in a flood zone uh
or if they tried to sell it it was in a
flood zone and this that this created
problems for them so is there is there
some way that you could check
well yeah there is but important to
point out that um in 2021 in New
Hampshire specifically um there was a a
great deal of change in the flood maps
flood maps change frequently um and in
2021 on the Sea Coast there was a major
revision that was that was done so
someone could very well have purchased a
home in 2018 that was not in a flood
zone when they go to refinance in 20123
it is in a flood zone everyone during
that initial purchase and sale did
everything properly they did their due
diligence realized it wasn't but now all
of a sudden they go to refinance and it
is and that happens relatively
frequently uh follow-up
question well actually I have another
idea on how to solve this problem so if
after my question if if it doesn't feel
like it solves it for you then then you
can ask your other question okay so
given that un under D it actually asks
the question the d uh one ask question
about these other products radon
Arsenic and Lead whatever how
about we working from this amendment
that you and I agreed on we add a
paragraph Roman numeral
five and we we don't tell we don't get
into the yes no parts we just get into
the part about uh and I was looking at
actually six
which is what is a flood zone and what
is insurance and that you know some of
that can we just take this some of that
language and narrow it down put it you
know short and sweet like we have with
radon and arsonic and lead to get to the
point that this is something that you
should be aware of and that this that
you know that there are blood maps are
available to you so you're talking about
putting it into the 4774 a just A1 one
paragraph Just Like These paragraphs are
written that are because if I if if I
remember and I am getting older but
because I feel like I was in the room
for all three of these I think all three
of these came to commer and my memory
was that we had we just had this one we
had this Roman numeral which helps
describe the problem to people that were
being
educational and then we had this D Roman
you know Roman numerals which had those
letters which actually was those
specific
questions I know you probably in Jump In
Joy with this but because I would we
need this paragraph done uh by tomorrow
morning or actually today so I can have
the amendment drawn up for tomorrow
morning adding this and had just
taking I'm sure represent M's worked
very hard in all this language so taking
this language and eding it to a short
and sweet paragraph which educates
people how important flood flooding is
an issue and that's why we're going to
ask this okay so that's an idea so we're
going to walk go around the room and
representative givs has her hands up
first so go ahead representative Gibbs
thank you um okay uh back to I I
actually now have two questions um but
back to my follow-up question earlier
okay um you were talking about what
might have happened in 2018 and so forth
but today if you're selling a property
and you can't interpret the flood map is
there somebody that you could call and
find out and get that flood map
interpreted and if there is shouldn't
you do that that's that's question
number
one possibly you should but I do think
put to have the M sorry I I I believe
that the bu it's important that the
buyer deter
that information they are the one buying
the property and they need to call the
call and find out if it's in a flood
zone so they have it from the horse's
mouth and then um my my second question
I'm afraid Mr chairman um uh is for you
and that is um uh as as I said earlier
it seemed like um uh the uh and
generally I'm not in favor of longer
language um but it seemed that the
longer language um in uh 128 uh did some
provide some additional Clarity and
specificity in terms of definitions and
so forth um so I I guess my question is
why would we want to uh eliminate that
that specificity because they have this
yes and no section so I'm not
eliminating it I'm just trying to get
this I'm trying to mirror what we've
already have in the statute and in the
statute we have
um I wouldn't call them you know short
paragraphs because they have multiple
sentences in them but that in those they
talked about radon Arsenic and lead and
so now we want to add flooding and we
want a
paragraph with enough sentences that a
let people understand how important this
is that they need to be you know to know
if they're in a flood zone and B where
they get the information to solve it and
that is we're talking about these flood
maps now we all can go on and on and on
about how how flood maps are are are
faulty but I'm sure you could say the
same thing about radon tests and arnic
test and let alone live whether you you
whether you don't know how long the
house really you know went when was the
last time it was painted so at the end
of the day all I was trying to do is
mirror what we did with those three have
a little paragraph in there about how
important it is but that the the meat of
the bill and the same thing for raon
artsn and Le the meat of the bill was
actually in
4-D which had those specific positive
actions that the seller must take to
help the uh but at the end of the day
and we all know what's happened this
last this last year everybody was buying
the houses with cash they weren't even
doing due diligence they were so worried
about trying finding make the sale okay
and that is a problem and we can't we
legislature can never fix that problem
but we all know at the end of the day
the reason why a purchase sale agreement
doesn't close the next day is because
there is due diligence requirements you
know and and and I'll have to say I
remember this this question way back in
when it came with rate onor that at the
end of the day it is the buyer's
responsibility to write in the purchase
sale
agreement that for before the closing
can occur XYZ needs to occur X you need
to fix that leaky porch B is you need to
do a radon test okay all those things
need can are normally written into it so
what we're doing here is we're
discussing things that buyers should be
doing but we all know that sometimes
buyers are who come from to stay or
unaware of radon or unaware of of of
lead on paint or something but now we're
adding another category and saying is a
we want to educate
them tell them where they can get it
answered have a place where they really
have to respond where that you know that
that's this is a checkpoint where the
Brokers have to say did the seller
answer those two questions
directly representative Ms you have a
comment just take that mic right there
that'd be
great how do you feel about my
compromise as usual I think it's a very
elegant elegant compromise I think I
could I could live with that um the the
the suggestion I would I would make in
terms of the language that you're
looking for is if you look at the the
amendment that I submitted 128 H
starting at 27 line 27 yep flooding um
you know I would I would I would include
that and at the end of line 29 what I
would then add is I would I would reord
line 29 to say you are encouraged to
examine your policy to determine whether
you are covered and the official flood
insurance map provided by FEMA for your
community and then end it there I think
that's what you're and then we again
that was the seller or the buyer this is
a a message to the we're trying we're
trying to educate the
buyer so so you have to say buyer you
you you can I guess you can ask the
seller for a copy of their insurance is
that is that appropriate you can't
really ask them for that but we are
asking them that they they identify
whether they have flood insurance well
what what I mean what the the the the
point that we're trying to make here is
that in terms of education is that uh
for a for a buyer a standard homeowners
insurance isn't going to cover you
against floods you've got to you've got
you're going to have to get we're
educating them about flood that's what
that's trying to get at and where at a
where you can get the flood insurance or
VI you should get it if uh if and then
put in in there that you know to get get
this National flood insurance Maps yeah
and and and I think the the other thing
is to
encourage and I I think we're probably
focusing on the buyer here now that I me
now that I think about it that to
encourage the buyer to go look the maps
to see for themselves whether there's a
problem if if so I think if you added
that that would be okay you could then
take out everything starting on line two
on page two through line 10 and then it
sounds like you're agreeable to leaving
section six which is kind of the
explaining what the hell we're talking
about you know what a flood zone is ETC
leave that in so through line 33 and
then everything else comes out the I
just don't want to be too long about
this okay I think if you put a and b in
it would be can I make a suggestion okay
because B has
the okay does have the map about the map
right so A and B Mr chairman can I make
a suggestion yes because we did
something like this with the Department
of Environmental Services on some of the
other issues where same issue it was
going to be very lengthy we put in the
website so if you look at arnik there's
a link link to a website that tells the
buyer as well as the agent where they
can go if we did those first two lines
and then put for additional information
go to fema.gov that's going to tell that
buyer and that agent where to go to get
additional information so
cnly one thing that we do we start out
with the arsonic right you said you're
going arsenic right arsonic is a common
ground water containment uh containment
in New Hampshire that occurs at
unhealthy levels in wellwater and many
areas of the state okay so we want to
describe flooding in one
sense yep right and then and then tests
are available and so we want to say yes
you and you can find out whether you're
in the flood zone and be aware that
flood insurance is not I think I think
it's important to let people know that
flood insurance is a is separate from
your homeowners sure I think that
sentence to me is I think is probably
helpful purchas and does say that that
within the due diligence you can you can
check for insurance regular insurance
and um availability and cost of flood
and please talk into the microphone
sorry our purchase and sale does say
that have two separate lines one for
just regular property insurance and a
second line for checking on the
availability and the cost of flood
insurance okay so that but that's
something you guys have in your document
but it's not statutorily required ired
like we do now
so it's okay but there are I guess there
are purchase sell agreements out there
that might not actually be you know
through the Realtors so we want we want
to use whatever you did there that
concept other words we're we're not
forcing you to do something you're not
already doing but we want it to have it
written in the statute does that feel
comfortable with that represent m a
quick question shouldn't this language
also be in the uh disclosure form as
well as the purchase we don't care at
this point we yes whatever they put in
the disclosure fir because that that's
what got us in the problem in the first
place because it had I don't know right
okay so we're not statuto we're not
modeling around in that disclosure form
that disclosure form is theirs and we're
not you know all our statute is
477 and what we want needs to be in 477
and 477 affects purchase and S so that's
not that's not complicated anymore more
than than we need
to okay so where we are
at is they're going to quickly knowing
what we have just asked for get this
done in a couple of
hours and then and then we can get it
out to everybody and then we'll keep
processing it so what I will be doing is
is I will be scheduling a
subcommittee tomorrow morning at
9:30 so that we
will what's
that so right now what we're talking
about is working from this amendment
right because I assume nobody has
problems with this being in the statute
okay but we're adding another paragraph
to this
amendment we're adding another paragraph
to this amendment that's going to say
it's going to be Roman numeral five and
and it's going to be short and sweet
about everything you ever want want to
know about flooding and flood
insurance yeah with a reference so
they right
correct okay does everybody feel
comfortable with that and that goes in
section 12 yes section 12 correct
purchase
sale could we just hear representative
Ms on that again
he already said that was a wonderful
idea excuse me his word was
elegant I'm I'm I'm fine with um you
know providing some language that
educates people
about uh the need for flood
insurance and um the need to consult the
um and I think it really is important to
say the official
um the official maps for the
community um as a a way to start
educating
people okay and then we can go from
there next
year excuse me and I'll be here I know
you will who is going to be responsible
for getting this amendment drawn up I
will okay
yeah what
up I need 24
hours okay we could all right
so okay well we'll say we'll say the
subcommittee will be at
11:30 and what we we could do yeah put
it get it in 11:30 and then we if I
assume the ex session might be done if
not we and then and then then she'll
then you'll need to say you need another
EXA uh exact session at at at
uh no it can't be the the second exact
session on this bill would be at
11:45 yeah let's do
that no thank you for catching me on
that one we might have more that's true
so we would start at 10: tomorrow we'll
still start at 10 tomorrow thank you
because I'm too late to do
anything okay we'll move on from that
one thank you all very much than you and
uh I'll be anxiously waiting waiting
from to hear from
you but thank
you okay uh all right next up is
1358 oh I just sent her
away
talk5 today tomorrow
tomorrow
uh 1694 okay I was one number
off
okay thank you chairman and committee
members my name is uh Lieutenant Matthew
Culver I'm a lieutenant with the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission division of
enforcement and Licensing the amendment
and Bill really before you uh deals
directly with contract brewing and or
contract manufacturing and tenant
manufacturing
um contract
manufacturing uh specifically is that
that you have a recipe to make a product
um and you give it to another
manufacturer that other manufacturer
makes that product for you very simply
put under tenant Manufacturing
is that you have a recipe you go into
somebody else's facility and make your
product using their
equipment so this bill expands what uh
expands what historically was for the
Brewers to make Beverages and beer is
expanding it out to Wine and Liquor wine
manufacturers and liquor manufacturers
as well uh we worked very diligently
with the New Hampshire Brewers
Association and many leading industry
members members to come up with the
extensive language that you see before
you but we wanted to make sure that the
language was right and that it was very
clear and made sense for um the the
different manufacturing license
types great any questions from committee
members all right uh ready for a motion
representative
pusk second by
committee moves ought to pass
on amendment number
1072 any discussion on the
motion see none all those in favor
please say I I those
opposed okay let's actually let's make
sure we so who's on this committee
now just this is just the liquor yeah
but why are all these names here because
she never knows who
it changes okay it changes okay right so
pusc is on here who else is on the
liquor one right I thought
so and how many get how many got
there solivan is on but he's not here
not here okay so but these four are here
and we have we have we have symmetry so
it's four to
zero okay representative pusk seconded
by representative buo moves ought to
pass as
amended okay all those in favor please
say I I those suppos so move damous
Sly
okay all right
next
back
Sor Chris oh
no okay you're not doing a Minority
Report on the New Hampshire banking
thing are you which one to create a New
Hampshire
Bank no he's doing the dispensing
machines and credit card who
voted he the only one vot
for the only
one oh so you were the one okay no I
meant the one vote I didn't mean you you
are the one you the one it's a crypto
bill you want to talk
okay so as we had in the last meeting we
decided I'm so
loud so you know when I'm in the old
committee room I just feel like you know
go back to the way I used to do
it okay uh as we had discussed in the
previous uh
subcommittee um we had decided that we
thought it was important that the
prescriber be notified if this uh
exchange um was was made
so representative mclair um thank you uh
my question is this I I was basically
not enthusiastic about this bill until I
read that an amendment I think or part
of it that said that the the patient
could refuse it does this not that's
still that's in the current bill correct
okay that's one right okay then
fine okay um M Mr chairman we we're on
the record as a subcommittee 50 interim
study so what do we do about that uh
with that's true the original committee
had voted for interim study so what
we're going to now do is take up the
question to to um um withdraw withdraw
our that motion
reconsider and who are the okay so I
I'll make the motion to
reconsider second and second by
representative
Burrows this is the health health
committee
said okay so the health subcommittee is
represent Gibs are on the health
subcommittee well we'll see we'll see
about that in a moment okay who else is
on the health subcommittee and insurance
is that insurance yes yes yes
okay
Vali
[Music]
you
okay here we go Insurance uh MCU prelli
hunt
Calabro Gibbs and
Burrows so uh you can replace
Gibbs oh excuse me not Gibbs but
umab collabro I'm sorry
collab so it's
helli bur gibs and
spear okay all right so the motion has
been made in second all those in favor
of may speak to that motion to
reconsider might as well because the
vote was interim study okay which is
what I prefer so all right you want
discuss it you can speak to the motion
of reconsider save me speaking to a some
other
time thank thanks um if I believe that
then I would have absolutely thought
that was a good idea than so I do think
interim study was the right decision
previously um it was this is one of the
most complex bills that we've dealt with
um I think I need a biosimilar of some
sort myself right now to correct the
sickness um but given the complexity of
this issue and given that the sponsor
himself sent out a nice FDA guidance a
subset of the FDA guidance just
yesterday
the FDA specifically
says that it supports legislation that
will classify biosimilars as substit as
substitutable with the reference
biologic but not with other
biosimilars which is what this bill aims
to do right this bill specifically and
I'll just quote the guidance for you the
quote the guidance says quote FDA is
seeking to amend section 351 of the P
Public Health Service Act that's the
thing that licens licenses biosimilars
to no longer include a separate
statutory standard for determination of
interchangeable interchangeability and
to and to deem all approved biosimilars
to be interchangeable with their
respective reference products and that's
the key part of this and that's where
our law difference with different
differs and it is an absolute difference
it's not a distinction it is a
difference a difference difference so
our our law on the top of page
two says regardless of the other issues
with this which are also complex our law
says that we want to allow something
that the FDA just cleared up doesn't
happen either here in any state or even
in Europe and they mention Europe
specifically in that guidance on the
second page of that guidance right below
what I just read you so I guess the
question before the committee is do we
want to do something that even the FDA
isn't suggesting that no other country
no other state suggests
and then separately the whole host of
other issues that we haven't studied
which is maybe it will reduce cost which
would be a great thing and I'm all for
it I'm for studying and finding a way to
do that but there is also a real
possibility that you'll be switched by
your pharmacist to an off formulary
medication that is a higher cost it's
just that simple we're giving the
pharmacist the power to do something
they don't currently have right now
pharmacists can can be prescribers if
and only if they have a collaborative
practice agreement just like a PA
functions under a doctor it's the same
thing and I I didn't make that up we got
it straight from the professor of
Pharmacy practice at Mass College of
Pharmacy that's our law so if we want to
put in statute A variation on the way
pharmacists currently practice
essentially expanding their practice and
actually giving them legal protection
for something that could go wrong
without studying it that's what we would
be doing and I think there's enough
issues cost safety it's great that we
have an amendment that says the patient
can refuse the patient can refuse any
drug any prescription now we they can
already do that and I think a lot of
patients who are in extremis and dealing
with cancer and dealing with tough
things I hope that all of us would call
our doctors but I'm not so sure that
every person dealing with cancer or if
the patient would even be there at the
time of dispensing that's the other
issue so there's just a lot of issues
with this we made the correct motion
before let's stay focus on we made the
correct motion before it was unanimous
50 itm study we've had lots of
information come before then and some of
it made it imminently clear that even
the FDA doesn't recommend what this bill
does so I'd ask you just to vote down
reconsideration representative
spear
no we're talking about
talk specific we're talking about a very
very small subset of biosimilar drugs
that have gone through further testing
with switching studies the switching
studies are
extensive and druggists are allowed to
switch those with the formulary right
now because they've been designated as
interchangeable biosimilars and that's a
small handful of drugs
we received a number of studies when we
were in this committee last time showing
how these were very safe we received
those studies from Europe and we receiv
received studies from uh some other
committee members that came in from
other you know like uh representative
Lon and her and her husband Dr
leyon and I went through those and I'm
sure everybody else had the opportunity
to go through those as well and as a
result of that it became very clear that
there are alternatives to the uh Rising
drug prices that we face and that this
bill gives us an opportunity to take
advantage of that for the very small
subset of drugs that have been gone
through switching studies they don't
have that designation switching studies
is not a designation they have in Europe
so they don't use it uh we received
uh some comments against this they were
conjecture they were opinion they did
not have the proof that we had that was
supporting this
bill the other problem the other thing
is we received uh support from the New
Hampshire Medical Society AARP nscl the
US Congress I have found support this
kind of an idea and are thinking about
writing a bill for it Medicare pbms and
the pharmacy associations of the
national and state
level we've been strangled over the
years by what we've been told drug
companies can do what we been told what
pharmacy can do New Hampshire has in the
past done some Innovative things with
drug laws and I with uh insurance
requirements this is a way that we can
give them a little tool it's Tool It's a
small tool that they can use to start to
begin to bring down drug prices and I
think it's very important that we take
advantage of this tiny little step and
go with it the uh the idea that we need
to study it some more there isn't
anything left to study we've seen 15
years of studies coming out of Europe
where they're interchanging drugs all
over the place we've seen 15 years of
Japan changing drugs it's time for us to
take that little step and I believe that
we have to do
this for
[Music]
governor thank you um I guess I I have
two points um which are I think fairly
uh perhaps simplistic um in reference to
the FDA guidance my understanding is
that things that are equal to the same
thing are equal to each other that is
that
if
um drug a is a biosimilar to drug B and
Drug C is a biosimilar to drug B sorry
if drug B is biosimilar to drug a and
Drug C is biosimilar to drug a then drug
drug B would be a biosimilar to drug C
and therefore they should all be
interchangeable that was how how I
understood it the second thing is in
reference to the pharmacy possibly
switching uh a lower cost to a higher
cost biosimilar it is always possible to
ask the pharmacist at the time of
dispensing what would be the cost of an
alternative formulation and I know this
is possible and I know that they answer
honestly because I have done this um and
found for instance that there was a
difference between something that would
cost $300 a month something that would
cost $1,100 a month uh which obviously
was a huge difference um so I think
those problems can be dealt
with yes if I recall correctly would New
Hampshire be the first state to enact
this type of leg evidently to represent
M says yes would be
is there a way that we could request
require some type of an evaluation after
say a one or a twoyear period to
determine you know what is the cost
savings if there were any issues because
if this is model legislation for other
states I'm sure they would want to
understand what our lived experience
would be so we could um add a sunset to
the statute and which would cause it to
I don't know if it's a sunset it's just
some type of a does what it has the the
effect of is having done uh a public
hearing process and and then decided
that you know whether this is approprate
and that's really you you remember the
pandas that that's really pandas was
sunset that was a five-year Sunset so
that after a period of time then you can
pause and and and uh in the public
hearing uh then people would have to
bring in and show that there was you
know what the good the bad and the ugly
I guess so that is a possibility we
could add a sunset fairly Cutting Edge
for state to do it it is something
different we're you know we're the
objective is to help patients and reduce
cost I would definitely like to see if
we're meeting those objectives okay so
somehow we're right now we're we're the
uh okay the right we're we're on the
still on the reconsideration motion
aren't we okay so that it right now
we're trying to decide whether
reconsider but that is uh something
another option yes represent a couple
comments were made about it could cause
a high an increase in drugs we have a
thing in here that says specifically
that they can only be offered if it
reduces the price they had to be a
reduced price correct so at least that
part of it that's already took care the
cost issue is already addressed minute
so um okay so the motion is to
reconsider and the uh so we have hunt M
brelli Burrows G
and spear all those in favor of
reconsidering raise your hand one two
three four five all those opposed so
five to one
okay so
um obviously this bill has to go on to
the
Senate and you know and and if uh
representative migu is you know is
convinced of his of of the logic of his
argument then I think he he could
certainly present it to the senate in
terms of adding a sunset to it I don't
know you know I mean I I I don't know I
mean I I would I would
assume that if if the FDA if knowing
that we pass it let's say we do pass it
and I assume the FDA will become aware
that we passed it that if they think
there was a problem then they they they
have abilities to take quick action and
and basically shut us down if they
thought
you know to say oh this is you know
wildly successful or beyond our
expectations or these are I know who
would do that that's the problem who who
would I don't like the insurance comp
the that's Department of Insurance I've
always treated this bill as an insurance
bill okay why did it come to us it is
true that re representative Merchant the
sponsor is from the Health and Human
Service committee and he assured me that
all his committee members are okay with
this bill okay so I take that for for
what it's worth so at this point U I
have I have not had any health in inate
anybody in the health system say that
there's a problem with this
bill and and yes all the insurance
companies think that if it's going to
lower lower cost to the consumer then
then that's a good idea so that's that
point where I was originally willing to
interim study it because of the of of
the nature of being so unknown and the
presentation we had at the time the
movement of the committee was to to
interim study it um obviously um in
hindsight and we you know so maybe said
maybe we we were a little rushed to
judgment on that interim study and I'm
and I'm comfortable with going ahead and
and passing this bill okay all right so
there's no way to issue a report it's
the sunset yeah well the best way to
that will happen is representative MCU
will do his research and he'll come in
and bring in a repeal B
and I I think probably next year you can
introduce a bill in regards to what you
want to see or kind of study you would
see yeah yeah it could certainly bring
in
another exactly now you get the
problem okay all right so uh we have a
mo representative who would like to
represent a spear seconded by
representative hunt moves up to pass on
the
amendment amendment
number
1028 okay any discussion on the on the
amendment all those in favor of the
amendment please say I I one two three
four five those
opposed that's unfortunate that means
you don't care about the position being
notified
okay just for the record I'd like them
to be notified in advance and I I talked
to you about that and the amendment
doesn't do that representative spear
second by representative hunt moves
ought to pass as
amended oh wait minut there's another
line I have to do another I'll do it
it's okay I'll get it I'll get you just
just just do a little circle you know
little arrows and say this is I'll do
that after okay okay so spere oh I see
because you see right because we did the
reconsider motion yeah yeah yeah
okay okay all right um any discussion on
the motion of about to pass as
amended was it an was it an amendment
that said at no additional cost or was
that in the original bill that was in
the original
bill I thought that was an amendment for
some that was in the original I I was I
was thinking I need an amendment then I
realized reading the bill it was already
there where where is it uh I'm looking
at it now okay well it's there
I saw a Redline amendment that I had an
amendment but it turns out that was
unnecessary it was already in the bill
so it was in a section arounded I think
I I where I don't have the bill in front
of me but you really we really want to
see it and know about it okay I don't
think it I don't think it says it so who
who it it was an interested party
amendment that brought it in okay
okay
for
Keith yeah hi oh
hi I have an email from rep Merchant
about we've had so many amendments I
can't tell any
thought I read the did there was a red
line amendment that had saw I that
amendment I thought when I read the bill
it
even if it even if it doesn't as I said
earlier um it's very easy for the
customer to guard against
that as I said I have done it
myself
and that was a concern that HHS
committee members had including rep
kofalt in
fact and one former member of this
committee guess we're going to be here
for tomorrow afternoon
now can
so that's his
expect I not seen yet I
believe could I could I pull the rest of
the committee real quick does
anyone second substitution performed
byes versus the business en
okay dispens not sure which one he may
use in the which would be earlier than
the three days in the current law so
this is something new well that's what
he was expecting but that the pharmacist
had to inform the prescriber at the time
of
dispensing so was that's not in the bill
well the
amendment this is something else when a
pharmacist dispenser which the
pharmacist inform the patient and the
prescri and the prescri found it days
found
it not sure which one he may use and be
earlier than the three days in the
current
law okay the current yeah the
current the current
law oh I see what you're saying okay so
he's saying
that I need a copy of this bill this is
why I hate not having the file here in
front of me nobody has the paper copy I
don't I hate looking electronically I'm
sorry I I need if I'm going to make an
amendment I need a paper
CP not a place I want to
go I'm with
[Applause]
you
okay the original bill says inform the
patient
on page
two um it's page two Roman numeral 4
that's what's in the current law up here
in Roman numeral
4 which is what we're amending when a
pharmacist dispenses an ining biological
product for the prescriber or biolog the
pharmacist or his neodestiny shall
inform the patient and then the
amendment says and the prescriber but it
doesn't give a time but the three days
to me the three days was the filing
electronic filing of the
prescription so I you know he's to me
he's confusing the
situation when if by saying that okay
but we could add so if we take out the
amendment that we have in front of
us okay we take out the am the
pharmacist B for the
prescrib
um the pharmacist and H shall inform the
uh um at the time time
of the dispensing when a pharmacist at
the time a pharmacist
dispenses using that dead P
again that time at the
time uh no because that's a whole
process the delay right and that means
the the patient won't get their medicine
as quickly as they would like to so
we're we are not going to worry about
that because the pharmacist is that the
patient the pharmacist has an obligation
to notify the the prescriber and if the
prescriber you says this is a bad idea
the prescriber can then take action call
they can call the patient and say don't
take it think there anyway
send okay no so here's the problem the
problem is you're opposed to this bill
so to say that you're trying to
negotiate in good faith you would have
to convince me that you're negotiating
it to make this a better build so that
you are ready to vote for it but if
you're never going to vote for it I'm
kind of tuning out what you're saying
I'm just telling you I'm just telling
you please talk into the mic oh yeah so
sorry what I think would make it way
more reasonable that I could even
support is if we tell the prescriber in
advance and I think there's an
opportunity in the typical work scenario
I get a prescription from my doctor they
transmit it electronically I'm usually
not very often not not usually standing
at the pharmacist ready to take it
across the counter okay they either
sometimes these types of drugs they
usually have to order these complicated
ones do you have the amendment uh that
he had done ahead of time uh probably
it's probably in it's in my email sure
and I I'm pretty much against doing that
because for the reasons you said I'm I'm
against doing that too because it's
timing it's a timing problem so but
right now what I'm want is this where we
put it in that it was going to be for
less
money no it was in an amendment I we
there were there was actually several
amendments
okay
all
right go
where
no he sent it to
me so
it's oh I
amend yeah
perfect thank
you okay so uh the amendment is already
drawn up so we already a me number so we
don't have to
wait we can have it
says at uh this is Roman numeral 8 if
you're looking at the bill in front of
you a pharmacist shall not sub uh
substitute an interchangeable biological
product that results in an increased
cost to the
patient so that's another another
amendment have two Amendment
so um thank
you
I I'm not really worried about his
amendment that that last comment about
at the time because it says when a
pharmacist dispenses an interchangeable
biological product for the prescrib the
pharmac shall inform the patient so I I
I I think that's okay you don't want to
I don't think we need to do it okay so
uh we have two amendments we're going to
take up would people like to have a copy
of the Second Amendment before they vote
on it yes okay I will have
them
okay okay all right so what we'll do is
we'll just uh take up we've already
passed
this yeah what do we pass now okay we've
already passed Amendment to pass then we
need another okay we pass that Amendment
so what we're going to do is we're going
to table this bill at this moment until
we have copies made of the amendment all
right and we'll move on to the next
issue okay
okay all
right next one is 1018 relative to on
premise off- premise liquor licenses and
of course I sent her out of the room
again do you want the bill do you want
the holder now they all need back
here
okay so I want everybody to know that
other committees who don't do
subcommittees would be dragging this one
bill out be doing this the fact that we
have this done by sub commmittee by the
time we except this tomorrow
okay you want to just remind us what's
all in here
thank you chairman committee members the
amendment for introduce yourself again
for the I'm sorry uh Lieutenant Matthew
Culver New Hampshire State Liquor
Commission division of
enforcement uh the
amendment is a couple uh uh clerical
issues um it's adding from the original
Bill a second license to distill you see
on uh line
that was unintentionally omitted out of
the original
Bill the amendment uh then added there
was an amendment to add the hookah
requirements to the cigar bar license
pursuant to RSA 17820
Dasa and in that there was a Omission
[Music]
on page two line Aid of that amendment
that changed the um letter
z uh
to level so where it
says on this bill that's before you uh
the amendment before you it's on page
two line
eight and that no level right level of
exposure to secondhand smoke is safe
that that level was a z it was a
clerical error was a Greek reference
LEL those are those are the changes in
this amendment there's a little too much
AI
involved okay any discussion on the
amendment okay so this is the liquor
committee so who we have on the liquor
committee uh
hunts pus right um burs
um and I know it's uh Sullivan but he's
not
here so we because we we're down to four
we were down to four there she is okay
Nita's back in the room okay so this is
just four of us yeah
okay so uh pusc and burrow okay so um
all those in favor of the in the
amendment is
0998 okay yeah you're you second
y 4 Z okay all those in favor raise your
hand yeah one two three four pass
unanimously okay representative pusk
second by represent
bullo
to
pass pass
amended all
right okay all those in favor say I I
one two three four those
opposed
unanimous okay we're done with that
one
toally y
right in my in my um efforts to save
paper I actually went found it yeah I
accidentally went from
two I went from one I went from two
sided one sided instead of one to two
and so now we have double paper now
double oh I see what you said that's
right you know I have that problem
because it computer sometimes they
default okay we'll uh take uh um House
Bill 1365 off the
table and uh take up the
uh Second Amendment and yes in case
anybody ever know yes you can have
multiple amendments on the same
bill
okay so representative spear second by
representative hunt moves ought to pass
on the amendment number
okay is there any discussion on the
motion okay seeing none this is the
health subcommittee so
it's belli Burrows Gibbs and spear all
those in favor say I representative
spear give Gibbs Gibbs I
okay and those
oppos represent me
you for the amendment okay okay great
all right so next so it's a un nameus
vote 6 Z 60 okay so now we have
representative spear I don't know if you
maybe didn't need to make another she
huh but we'll be fine I I would just
flip it over do the back side okay I'll
do that representative spear seconded um
by representative hunt moves ought to
pass as
amended yep okay any discussion on the
motion yes representative
spear New Hampshire has always been uh a
supportive of new ways to reduce the
cost of insurance coverage for the
prescriber and this is really an
excellent opportunity for us to find
finally make a dent with respect to the
coverage for drugs so as far as the
insurance companies are concerned this
is a win and as far as the prescribers
that are concerned this is a win so I
I'm very encouraged by the fact that
we're going to take this first step and
be very Innovative in this area as we
have been in other areas of legislation
that this committee has taken up so I
encourage everybody to vote
OTP a
tpaa
[Laughter]
a okay the motion is ought to pass as
amended and amended twice just for
clarification all right is the question
clear representing you one more time
yeah so I still think inm study is the
best thing I'm glad we passed the
amendment to make it clear that it won't
increase cost to the consumer
unfortunately there is no such thing as
a study to sub one interchangeable for
another so that's a misnomer I hope the
blurb doesn't say that because that'd be
misinformation and the bill is really
not about drug costs right there's a lot
of ways to lower drug costs um
prescriber may win pharmacist may win
patient loses support interim study
that'll be the Minority Report which you
already
have
okay uh any more discussion on the
motion see none all those in favor of uh
to pass as amended please raise your
hand one two three four five and those
oppos got it okay five to one
yep all right moving
on a request that we go through M asked
if we could finish some this morning not
take a lunch break okay yeah that's fine
okay so um all right so this is by so
this was O
tpaa and that was
spear
okay all right and we just took care of
1018 right
y because we we passed it we had we
passed the amendment and the bill right
okay
yep okay okay and
okay okay next
12:41 relative uh relative to regulation
of money
transmitters um sure we can do
1296 anything to get you out of the
[Laughter]
room
wow getting a little bow there
oops what's
that it's a little stuffy in here is
that what you're saying yeah okay
represent M you want to open that
window already open well there's two two
the one I looking at doesn't look like
it's open at all well you see it's
unlocked but just shove it open there
you
go
right but that was forward to everybody
anyway so yeah
so
two thank
you
okay all right so um the amendment of
House Bill 1296 that's in front of you
is just pushing out the effective date
to January 1st which is a traditional
what we do with um any health insurance
mandate is uh because that's when really
begin the process of new uh contracts uh
go out um
so I would like to make a
motion happy to move out the pass I will
make the motion
okay yeah
pretty so the amendment Number
and seconded by Rend
Burrows okay so uh motion is made in
second is there any discussion on the
motion see none uh this is the health
committee okay all those in favor say I
I one two three four five
six okay um I'll make the motion about
to pass as
amended
okay and
um you recognize to speak to my motion
um so the reason why I'm making this
motion is I'm going to make sure in the
blurb in the excuse me I'm not supposed
to say that in the committee report is
to make clear that the committee
intention with this bill is in terms of
passing it is that this test this
machine this special machine is being
done because the the mamography that we
do mandate
now is is is uh unclear and that they
need to to have another exam and that
and that's why we're uh we're waving the
deductible and copays U because this is
really a followup to that mamogram
test okay so the motion is ought to pass
as amended any
discussion all those in favor say I 1 2
3 4 5 six six those opposed
unanimous and we're good to
go okay so I only have two
left
12:41 money
transmitters SC them
away
I guess I should have done that one
first
huh oh they had nothing better to do
today
right yes
please
all right so um we have a question right
off and the money transmission means any
of the followings what is what is stored
value that that was the Compromise right
for the uh
was that that was the those guys the
payday company the pay payroll companies
that hold on to was this the compromise
uh I'm sorry can you which section are
so I'm on page 10 I mean page line line
10 excuse
me of the bill or of the amendment on
the amendment I actually haven't seen
the the official oh you didn't get one
okay sorry no that's
okay uh
um well first just by introduction I'm
Bob lamberty from the banking Department
um that section Roman uh numeral 18 yes
that was amended in part as part of the
changes made uh in conjunction with the
payroll processing uh group stored value
is defined elsewhere in the bill
um in the definition
section it's Roman numeral uh 2 eight
that's that's going to be in the current
in the current bill that's in the bill
the original bill so you're going to
pull up the original
Bill the internet's a little slow in
this corner of the
building that's it up there is do we
have a copy of the original B uh you
were given one months ago yes I don't
know where it
is pulled up the
original I do do you want to go sit next
to her and and not necessarily
I should have brought my computer
because I've got I got it in my computer
we have original bill in there for him
oral
bill I already read it yesterday so uh
all 32 Pages
yes yeah most of it's boiler plate but
uh I'm interested in the cryptocurrency
business
thanks well I'm glad you're interested
in
something yeah this is been
big deal for
me
okay so what does it say for store value
and and if you had now that you had the
original what what page is that is that
on in the original bill it's on page
five starting on line
nine so I see uh where am I at here oh
you're at okay there's something called
so page one on line 27 there's closed
loop stored value closed loop stored
value is different
than on page
one yeah definition yeah what is what is
closed Loops door value what that page
five has stored value right so you have
you have two you have the closed loop
and then separately you got some
splaining to do here stored
value explain the
difference well admitted it's been a
little while since I looked at these
definitions we'll give you
time to think about
it page five is where stored value is
explained is it proper for me to ask why
uh we have this legislation to begin
with okay yes I can answer that question
so um we actually had had heads up about
this last
year that this legislation was coming
down the pike and that um we're
we had already taken care of getting rid
of uh the the licensing of ATM machines
I don't know if you remember that those
are all it's all of this this is like
this is a recodification of a whole
business uh of our of
our they call you money transmitters but
it's really our what what would you call
this department this is the um of the
bank Department what division is this in
this would be Consumer Credit division
Consumer Credit division that's what I
was looking for yeah okay there it goes
right there in the
title
okay so the consumer credit division
because the banking Department not only
regulates Banks but then we can regulate
Consumer Credit so this can go all to
Consumer Credit includes you you know
small
loans and payday loans
even uh you know all those different
divisions so then uh in that division in
that thing we we have been uh somewhat
working around the issue of the um that
was also in this division was
technically your crypto was some was
actually had got dabbled in here because
it was considered a commodity but more
importantly was um money transmitters
what is the issue of if you I go to the
old Western Union but I got I flunk the
Western Union test when I was trying to
send money to my daughter so I just went
down to my local
Walmart and they tell you which Walmart
do you want to send the money to and
instantly I sending money to my daughter
who was in San Francisco it was a Marvel
but yes that there those money
transmitters are
regulated under the section are there
different types of so wanted to pull the
thing
closer
um there are obviously a lot of
different uh versions of of money
transmission or the reasons for money
transmission and I noticed in the
amendment to House Bill
1241 uh there
is uh section
four for purposes of this section A
license C that issues proprietary
cryptocurrency non-fungible tokens or
other digital assets shall not include
the value of such assets when
calculating tangible net
worth and I explained that to you well I
did you like my explanation you made a
stab at it I I uh you're calling me
making a stabin no I was very
straightforward that the banking
department when you're being regulated
by the banking Department we want your
balance sheet right and we are going to
go over that balance sheet with a fine
tooth comb right right and if you think
that you can write in Goodwill or some
other uh intangible value such as oh we
issued these these crypto coins and
they're worth $100 and we issued you
know a thousand of them so I'm going to
put a million dollars into my balance
sheet they're going to
say we are going to disregard that and
there's a few more sentences that follow
I'm just cutting it cutting it making it
short for purposes of calculating net
worth under this section yes
cryptocurrency non-fungible tokens or
other digital assets shall be considered
quote proprietary quote but if when such
assets are developed or created by the
licensed entity exactly so we're talking
about the creation of a currency no do
not confuse us with digital
mining no I'm not confusing it with
mining or digital mining or otherwise
nothing in this parag graph shall
prevent a licensed entity from including
the reasonable value of cryptocurrency
non-fungible tokens or other digital
assets developed or created by other
entities and held as assets when
calculating tangible net worth is
this has this particular
section been always been uh uh regulated
by the banking
Department the short the short answer is
no um and that's it's been added as part
of the the model act in response to
specific
instances that uh the dep departments
seen on the national sphere with regard
to uh crypto firms and inflated values
of tokens in so far as they affect the
balance sheet and the reason that was
added in this case was because the
Department's trying
to uh provide some protection to
consumers in instances where there are
Bad actors um like FTX that's really the
the biggest one that we've seen there
are a couple others I think where
similar issues have Arisen but that's
what this particular paragraph is
designed to uh protect against does the
bank have any estimation of how
much cryptocurrency
uh and and also uh changing
cryptocurrency for dollars etc etc has
the banking Department done any study
that would indicate how much of this
activity would be done in New
Hampshire if this became laws as written
as as you know recommended
here I guess I'm are you asking how much
money transmission is being done or
that's that's two different questions
you're asking if if you want to ask is
how much money transmitting that's going
on between turning currency into Bitcoin
different currencies and it has nothing
to do with this section of the bill this
section of the bill is solely about the
solvent solvency of the financial
institution that is being licensed it
has nothing to do with what they do for
a business okay and that's what you're
asking is a separate question question
your separate question is how much
activity is going on between uh
translating taking Bitcoin or excuse me
that's a brand name but taking for
instance Bitcoin
to fiduciary
currency I have another question which
follows on that if you're going to
regulate something uh you become
responsible for it and you mentioned as
a matter of fact protecting the uh under
the consumer affairs routine um do you
have any idea do you have the
infrastructure uh to
actually regulate um what could be a
multi-billion dollar industry in New
Hampshire uh yes uh and I say that
because we currently do
um the exemptions that exist for money
transmission related to cryptocurrency
they're not changing so
the entities that we regulate and
oversee in theory won't change at all
with the passage of this of this bill
this is designed to uh make the
regulatory uh scheme more efficient and
easier for the Department to coordinate
with other states on a nationwide basis
that sort of thing so all right I'm I'm
I'll I'll go with that the other my my
next question is then why why are we
saying these things in writing what is
the current uh regulatory
environment that you are are working
under well this section as
representative hunt said relating to the
balance sheet and how the the assets and
liabilities are calculated we don't have
standards for that part of it in the
current money transmitter law so the the
model act has what are called credential
standards for um net worth permissible
Investments that sort of thing and this
is just one sort of subset of that so
that's a new addition um this this
section that you're referring there
could you define the word proprietary
for
me in in this context what it's designed
to to capture are
uh cryptocurrencies tokens Etc
electronic assets that are created or
developed inhouse so if I'm a company
and I uh develop a a digital currency or
token I can't
then essentially what we've seen create
a value for that and put it on my
balance sheet as an asset because what
happens is the company would then have
an
overinflated uh value and so consumers
and the public think it's worth a lot
more than maybe it is and so this is
designed to kind of bring that trust in
the balance sheet and the enity uh back
has it has to be publicly traded it has
to be that there's other other
third-party people have actually done
something with that that product and
said yeah you know that the value you
have on it is a free and open market in
other words it needed to be on the New
York Stock
Exchange so that that is a publicly
traded but if you just go and you know
print paper on your you know on your
computer you print paper and say all of
a sudden this this Paper Stock and this
stock is worth you know $100,000 per
piece no if nobody is going to pay you
$100,000 for it then it's not it's not
legitimate it's it's proprietary well
you you can say when bitcoin's value is
it's right on the ticker in the New York
Stock Exchange that's correct so so the
so the crypto has transactional value
correct the problem is if you're going
to go and use it as collateral for a
loan of some sort then you have to uh
then you have to do it in dollars or I I
would think and and I the end of the day
is the value is only as good as the
other person treat FS that has value
well you're GNA I would I I would ref I
would reference what Bitcoin is going
for or ethereum or some whatever that is
these these things are actually uh
already costed out so it's not a matter
of again the costing out is because it's
publicly
traded not because they just created
inhouse and gave its own proprietary
in-house value that's the
difference you want to try yeah go ahead
ke Mr chairman may I try to clarify this
from my own understanding uh is it it
along the same questioning that he is
otherwise you're saying it's it's
clarifying hope hopefully to be sure
that I understand the same the answer to
the same issue okay okay if I am a LIC
if if I own a company that's a licensed
entity and we create some cryptocurrency
and assign it a particular value and
issue it we can't count that as part of
our tangible net worth but if my my
company owns some
assets owns some cryptocurrency as
assets and that cryptocurrency has not
been issued by my company but rather by
some other company and has some market
value then we can count that as part of
our tangible net worth have I understood
that correctly that is exactly right
yeah thank
you okay Keith all right so I I uh I I
like language that you guys came up with
for the proprietary aspect um so I have
no issue with that that makes perfect
sense you know I could create a million
tokens sell it to one person for a,
dollar for one token and all of a sudden
I have a billion dollar market cap for
my asset that no one else values right
so right that would be a bad actor we
want to keep them out of our economy um
I just want to go back to that stored
value uh definition I just want to make
sure we're not in inadvertently pulling
in Virtual currency into that stored
value definition because that would sort
of defeat the whole purpose of exempting
it uh which we did originally back in
2017 so yes what why don't you read us
what the definition of stored value is
so there's a couple pieces of it before
you do
um it says uh sword value means monetary
value representing a claim against the
issuer evidenced by an electronic or
digital record and that is intended and
accepted for use as a means of
redemption for money or monetary value
or payment for goods or services so it
says it's electronic or could be
electronic and then it says the term
includes what is not limited to prepaid
access on and on so not the not limited
to could pull in anything right so um I
just want to make sure it's not
inadvertently I know it isn't your
intention but it's it's it's the idea of
of a credit debit a card that's been
pre-loaded with value that's my
understanding that was my so so the
issue is you don't actually
say card or account or you don't you
don't kind of limit in terms because
when you have that language is kind of
open-ended it it appears that it it goes
beyond from what we intended it to be
which was the stored value cards because
we're using that to take care of the
mayor's problem so so maybe add
something like uh this does not include
virtual currency to Virtual currency
transactions because that's really the
exemption
there I think that's certainly in line
with my understanding of how this works
all all said I don't have an issue with
adding it I think if I'm looking at this
you know with my attorney hat on I would
go to the definition of money
transmission and then the exemptions uh
to as a sort of starting point and the
exemption that has been there since
2017 uh is still there and that exempts
the um
the solely and cryptocurrency that I
think you're referencing there but if
it's it's a matter of making paragraph
has been there all along yeah so do you
mind putting that as a bill in for next
year well or I can we can amend a bill
we do it non doain hearing and add it to
another bill I just think if somebody
from out of state is coming and reading
this for the first time they might get
the false impression that it includes
virtual currency so maybe reference the
exemption in the definition of stored
value in paragraph
28 of the original Bill the uh of the
original bill right maybe put an
explicit reference to the exemption that
you just mentioned in that definition
that way if somebody's reading it for
the first time they're not
confused I'm happy to to to do that it
be pretty simple okay I mean that's what
he's saying right all right so I need
that Amendment ASAP so that I can
yesterday so if you can go home get have
that dra up and sent over to me and then
we'll get that to legislative Services
yep I can do that that makes sense I
still have a bunch of questions by the
way uh well that's St value is uh among
them okay so I mean this I I have to uh
you know I'm an old school dollar guy
okay so uh the thing is um stored value
means monetary value represented
representing
a claim against the
issuer I don't know if you're issuing
crypto but uh against the issue
evidenced by an electronic or digital
record
so what am I looking at if I'm if I want
to see what the real value is and you
give me a digital record or some
electronic
proprietary uh and
digital
thing and and called the debit card um
do you have a debit
card yeah sure but I mean so that debit
card has stored value and the stored
value is your bank yeah and that you
know that how you all you have to do is
go online with your bank well I don't do
I don't do any business in crypto no
we're not talking cryp what I'm trying
to get at is this crypto business to me
is new now we're we're specifically
going to put in a in that stored by you
that it can't be crypto it can't be that
that well I mean the Providence is money
laundering so you can take crypto and do
dollars Providence that would
be but there you are I mean if if if I
have a th000 crypto uh coins and on the
market they each are worth
$3,000 that's real collateral I'm I'm
assuming it's going to be taken for real
collateral if your financial institution
is willing to use that as collateral
maybe Donald Trump should know about
that because he's had trouble finding I
well I'm sure he's he's he probably
working on it but the if he had some
crypto maybe some people have which is
why I asked which is why I asked about
the infrastructure at the bank I don't
think this is a a minor matter what I
know about this
issue okay
was
that we have payroll
companies that do not issue checks they
do direct deposit and they they give
actually stored value cards am I am I
going up the right stored value what
cards digital record it's a digital
record stored value and so what this was
about uh why we even you know that it
was always in there but this was it
ironically used as one of our exemptions
to take so that our small instate
payroll companies don't get swallowed up
with this regulation where the where uh
the most famous one is the ADP you know
the payroll company is is going to be
regulated because they actually issue
stored
value I they they issue a card but they
had the stored value okay um think
stored value means dollars
now make a translation for me about all
this cryptocurrency business well you're
the one who's making that leap no no
it's in it's right here I didn't write
this thing Keith is is saying is he
wants to make sure that with that term
store value yeah that we are
specifically making sure it's not crypto
so you should be ecstatic about his
Amendment because he's clearing it up to
make sure that no one ever thinks that
crypto can be stor
valued he's going to do dollars just
like everybody else that's what we want
that paragraph to be which was at some
at some part of the the chain was
crypto you can't get rid of crypto For
Heaven's
Sake you're looking for regulating here
I mean I can give you mortgages I mean
we can go talk about property and by the
way the the Securities and Exchange
Commission said crypto is a
commodity I just think this is a jumbo I
I don't understand how he's I have been
saying that by the way to you yeah for
the last six years after I would sat
through whole summer of those whole
hearing about crypto and I have said it
once I said it twice I think everybody
else in the room has probably heard me
say it it is a commodity it is not
dollars it does not have Financial value
we called it the banking Department
called it Beanie Babies yeah that's what
it goes remember the Beanie Baby discuss
com across the New York it's a commodity
and all I know is why I would never do
crypto because as someone who his family
made its money in a
commodity I would not want to hold a v
something that the value is only with
somebody else perceives it to be that
it's a commodity that is not a commodity
it has no tangible things it's not
silver it's not gold and certainly not
aluminum could be
plastic okay so I I at this point uh I I
I don't think we really can help you
with your answers you feel like you're
you're chasing your tail and and you
know and we understand you I'm just not
seeing the need for the business I got
you fair enough okay so uh you'll work
on getting that that Amendment so we're
when I back end this
subcommittee we just replace we could
just we'll add it as a separate
Amendment because because that stored is
that that's not in this amendment now
right so just that'll be a second
amendment it'll be just so I'm clear
just a new Amendment with everything Al
together the only thing that amendment
is is going to be is that stored what is
the RSA the it's it's the definition
stored by value and we just want to say
I put it some you know saying this does
not
include digital reference the exception
that's already there yep so somebody can
follow just reference the exception
perfect okay love that
yep it's
not okay kill that one so at this point
we're just gonna uh we'll set this aside
and we'll we'll take up both amendments
tomorrow okay all right thank you sir
will make you come back tomorrow I'm
sure you had better things to do
but thank you
guys uh yes please schedule another
subcommittee uh at this point uh might
as well go ahead do that for
11:15 1:15 and then and then and then
exec session add
two oh I just suspend the exact I don't
have to do anything perfect I just have
to have notice about subcommittees ex
okay so so you could say so if you can
go quick and 12:30 tell her to do 12:30
12:30
yeah that's lunch time I
Lun we hopefully we get everything done
and we all go out to lunch and I'll
buy okay get it all done now we're
talking okay all right last but not
least
condos I did this again I sent her out
of the
room oh what what the amendment for 1129
do we we have an amendment for it or do
we
um representative Herbert could I have
the bill back for the for the file the
one I gave you you it no the bill
yep thank
you
you're fall
back
when Senor moment always in the
community room but okay I will try my
best
here so um this is uh not that we passed
a lot
of no This was um it'll come to me and
say as soon as I walk out the room the
name will come to me
um so that what we're going to tr is um
this is allowing condominium
associations to have proxies because
that was the big one of the is issues is
is is getting condo members to show up
and and the big issue was to clarify
that the proxy um it was not a a generic
proxy that it had to be it had to be
specific the actual votion actual issue
and it had to be up and down and um so
theoretically this amendment takes care
of that
what highly worried about was that we
took out time
shares
so so um I will to
pass
yes I'm yeah um if I remember when the
bill was introduced it was
representative Aly and representative
infantine and representative infantine I
think uh was sort of against passing the
original version of the bill correct
he's he's okay with this amendment that
was my question thank you
yes and they're looking for people who
want to join the the oversight
board God those are like the plague they
are okay okay so representative hunt
second by representative burough moves
to pass on the amendment number not on
oh okay that's all right never mind who
is on who is on this committee I think I
am m is on and Cole's on yeah so M
because he's a
Dem
yes you are believe it or not you're on
condos yeah this is
business okay so it does include spear
does include
Herbert
right okay okay
so uh yes Ammon is on the
sub yeah exactly okay so representative
hunt seconded by representative
M uh moves ought to pass on amendment
number
0871 okay any discussion on the
motion see none all those in favor raise
your hand two three four five
six okay
representative
hunt second invite representa unless
somebody else wants to be a condo
King to pass as amended and okay all
those in favor on the motion please
raise your hand one two three four five
six and we're good to
go
and that's it right
okay all
right so tomorrow we'll start at
10: and we'll uh do you know
these um Tech technically we have the
motion is to exact go into EXA session
what I'll probably do is um I'll I we
have we have unfortunately have time
specific on when these subcommittees are
going to meet so we'll we'll exec
everything that's we can until up to
that time specific then we'll recess the
exact session take up the Amendments
these two amendments or whenever the
timing of those two amendments and then
go back into exact session and and then
hopefully we'll have everything all done
tomorrow and then
blurbs executive you know committee
reports you know
remember I am trying to write down this
time I have done it you know but I and
and other times I I would been a bad boy
and wasn't writing names down so but
we'll try to stay on top part of the
problem is I don't always hear who gets
a sign so whoever's makes we the the
policy been whoever makes the
motion and there and there in lies the
other problem I don't remember who
motion right well that that it's all the
more reason why I need to make sure that
I have it done I I'll try to I'm going
to I'm I'm going to have my homework
done with all the ones we've done and do
a spreadsheet like we usually do which
unfortunately I haven't done didn't do
those last time you can have access to
this one keep track of's making oh okay
yeah you want to send me that can you
send me can you send me to me yeah last
week did you update from what we
actually ended up doing this is what we
talked about in exact last week I can do
tomorrow and then send you okay okay
yeah just send it as an Excel file so um
Carrie 1365 today today's bill you were
you made the motion so you'll be writing
the the BB the
report
e
for